hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book two of his work on anger
particularly in chapters 26 and 27
Seneca is going to examine our tendency
to have the wrong objects of our emotion
of anger and I'm using that word objects
quite deliberately because we typically
think about it in terms of things
themselves so for example this book is
an object my tie is an object I am my
body are objects as well but object can
also mean the thing that something is
directed towards and in this case the
towards is anger right we feel anger
towards a number of different things and
just to give you one of his examples he
says we've thrown away a book because
the writing was too small or torn it
into pieces because it was a bad copy so
we've got the emotion of anger at the
book book and we also have the action
throwing it away tearing it into pieces
we can do all sorts of other things with
books as well that could display our
anger towards this object and Seneca
says that's really kind of you know
insane if you think it through and so
you know he tells us we could think we
get angry with things that can't
actually wrong us they can't do us in
urea right and this is beyond just
hurting us or damaging things for us
this involves a kind of deliberate
intention to do so you know wanting to
insult us to humiliate us and a little
bit later he's going to say things that
actually lack will
Vela
literally those things that are not
capable of willing right of exercising
choice or which lack any sort of
intention a concilium plan you know
deliberation or anything like that we
shouldn't get angry at those those are
not good objects for us to get angry
because they don't choose to do anything
wrong to us they they can harm us right
so he has the example of a sword or a
stone these things can definitely harm
us as a matter of fact so can the book
you know you're reading it oh I got a
paper cut right but the book didn't
intend to it didn't choose to give you a
paper cut we're not living in some
cartoon where inanimate objects develop
eyes and you know decide to do things no
they're they're
they're inanimate they don't have the
capacity even to move themselves let
alone to decide for themselves and so he
says that it's really stupid and he uses
that word there stoltum right to get
angry at things that as he says don't
deserve don't meruit right or even feel
santiare they don't feel our anger you
know I can take this book and rip it
apart if I want to or do whatever else
I'm going to do to display my anger
throw it on the ground the book doesn't
care the book doesn't feel anything
right that's basically what it means to
be not only inanimate but but in the
sense that as well and so in all of
these cases where you know he's going to
give you another great example here
we've ripped up garments because they
were displeasing right you get your
shirt now sometimes they're displeasing
because you can't fit into them anymore
you you know you try to get into your
stuff from high school or college in
your middle aged and you know you're
jamming yourself into the shirt and it
doesn't fit
it's not the shirt's fault the shirt
remained the same your body changed over
time right and we can say the same thing
about so many other things get mad at
our vehicles our cars our bikes uh pick
whatever else you want because they're
slowly breaking down and not performing
as well as we demand and think that they
should well that's that's our fault
we're the ones who are actually creating
our own anger
now Seneca does
an entertain an interesting objection so
somebody might say well we're not really
angry at the thing itself we're actually
angry at the maker the artifacts of the
thing the craftsperson if you like and
you know you could say well there's some
Applause ability to that and think about
you know some examples like so I've got
a cup and I'm drinking out of it and
suddenly the handle breaks off I'm like
oh this damn Cup right should be like
that stupid company Bed Bath and Beyond
I'll never buy anything from them again
some shoddy products right okay that
would be an example where you are
complaining about somebody in the supply
chain it may not be that Bed Bath and
Beyond actually made the cup themselves
they bought it from some other company
that made it there might be like 23
steps in the supply chain but somebody
is responsible right it's a little bit
more direct when we're talking about a
book Because unless we're talking about
the you know we might say material
aspects of it a book is designed to
convey information to us so I could be
reading Seneca and I could be like damn
that Seneca I can't believe he's telling
me not to get angry at books you know
I'm angry at this book right here where
Seneca is telling me this and that okay
well then you're angry at Seneca you're
not really angry at the book per se and
you probably shouldn't take it out on
the book you should
I don't know find seneca's uh Monument
or a bust of him and smash it up with a
hammer or something like that but even
that is quite quite foolish right so
what about the makers Seneca says well I
got three things to say to you the first
is most of the time that people are
angry with inanimate objects they're not
making this distinction they're not
talking about the maker they're not
saying you know I'm I'm projecting my
anger at this book but it's really
Chicago University press that I'm angry
at for making such a waxy cover I don't
like this right no you're just mad at
the book I don't like this your tide
doesn't tie properly you're like damn
this stupid tie you know pick whatever
else you want our technology is you know
like that as well when the Apple phone
doesn't work quite as as we intended to
you know an app fails we get angry at
that we don't say damn you Apple
Corporation you know so we we really do
focus on the thing rather than the maker
and then he says you know another thing
you could say well maybe the makers
could offer reasonable excuses and it's
interesting that excuses is just you
know a transliteration
exclusationes right yustas meaning just
not just reasonable but right
appropriate excuses for their product
you know and what could those excuses be
well you know one of them might be that
things just aren't made uh as well as
they they could be given the materials
that we have you know this one couldn't
do better than he did it wasn't for the
purpose of insulting you that he didn't
learn better the other one didn't do
what he did with the aim of offending
you and you know if you think about our
existence where we don't know the makers
of 99 of the objects that were in close
contact with this actually makes a lot
of sense those makers could say hey I
worked with the materials that I had I
don't even know you buddy there's no way
I was doing this just to take you off or
anything like that and then finally
Seneca says it's crazy and here's the
translation to vent spleen it's actually
bile in the
Original Latin but we often say in our
English language to vent spleen meaning
to display anger against objects instead
of people so if you're really mad at the
book
take it out on the author if you're
really mad at the car I guess go to the
dealership or go to the corporation if
you're really upset about the uh you
know drink that you ordered that wasn't
mixed just perfectly don't get pissed
off at the drink complain to the
bartender right we could go on and on
and on in this this way it's crazy to
direct your anger against the wrong
objects
now he expands this a bit going beyond
the realm of inanimate objects per se
but carrying forth the same lessons
about lacking will lacking intention and
thereby not wronging us
he talks about animals right and he's
got an example some people think they're
being held in contempt from the same
horses that obey one Rider defy another
as though some things are not are more
submissive to some people deliberately
not as a result of habit or the
Handler's skill so you know you go to
somebody's house and they've got a cat
and you're a cat person and you're like
here here kitty kitty and the cat like
ignores you that's
there's nothing like intentional there
the cat's not like screw that guy you
know I want to piss him off no it's just
the cat is used to its owner and maybe
it's a little shy you know or you start
scratching the cat it comes up to you
and it rolls over on its belly and you
start scratching its belly and you're
like oh this is so nice right and then
suddenly it does the typical thing or it
unleashes the claws and grabs you bites
you and starts digging at you with it
it's back claws or a bad cat it's doing
what cats do you know it's playing with
you you could take it a different way
and so he says listen animals don't have
the same sort of capacity for willing
and deliberation that we humans do so it
you shouldn't get angry at them any more
than you would at a book and we can go
further with this we can extend this to
children to immature human beings right
who are still in the process of
development now kids are off and kind of
jerks you know we've all been one I
think you can look back on your own
memories of what you did and what you
suffered and realize that now we're
getting to some more intentionality but
Seneca is going to say that it's stupid
to become angry with children and at
foolish human beings right those who are
as he says uh not much more thoughtful
than children and the word that he uses
for thoughtful there's prudencia and he
says that they're not distanced from the
they're not greatly distanced from the
amount of prudence or practical wisdom
that children have which is practically
none so there are many adult human
beings who are quite you know stupid
insane foolish themselves and why are
you getting angry at them they are you
know not much greater than some sort of
tool or or other inanimate object that
you might run across
the last thing that he considers and
this is in uh chapter 27 is
um nature in the gods now you know
Seneca does believe that there are Gods
who effectively run the universe the
stoics believe that there was you know a
God uh you know with a capital G Zeus
who is sort of running the whole show
and then there are the lowercase G Gods
who are each doing their part to like
govern things and make sure that things
go right including the seasons and
natural phenomena you know you can think
about these uh you don't like having the
wind blowing in your face you're getting
wet when it rains or hailstones falling
on you or stuff like that and then a lot
of people he says who are insane or
ignorant of Truth they get angry at the
gods they're like why did you do this to
me why are you raining down on me when I
I'm dressed up for going out on a date
or to you know a job interview view now
everything is going to be ruined it's
your fault I tell you right and so here
they're getting angry because of the
natural phenomena and they are unlike
you know with the makers or Seneca says
yeah most of the time you don't blame
the maker they are blaming the maker and
what they're not realizing is that these
natural phenomena they work in a natural
way the way that they are set up and
there isn't again there's no
intentionality there to do harm to hurt
us to screw with us instead it's just
setting things up for our benefit I mean
the rain is coming down and when the
rain is on you you could be like well
it's too bad I got caught in the rain
but man this sure is great for like
washing all the dirt and grime away from
this ugly City it's going to look a
little bit nicer now or you could be
like well I'm happy it's raining because
the rivers aren't going to run dry and
we'll have fish in them and I can go
fish or a kayak or do it whatever we're
going to do you or you know wow it's a
good thing that it's raining so we don't
have a drought so we can actually
produce vegetables and farm other things
you know there's different ways of
looking at it he says None of these
things happen with the aim of rying us
the opposite none of these things happen
save for our well-being so we have all
sorts of animate and inanimate objects
that we shouldn't get angry with in
every case Seneca is going to say nobody
is actually trying to do you wrong
nobody is trying to screw with you
nobody's trying to humiliate you
nobody's trying to damage you
deliberately if it happens you know the
sword or the stone or the natural
phenomenon or the you know dog barking
at you and scaring you or something like
that it's not just to be jerks to you
it's because this is the way the
universe works and so if we don't want
to be crazy we should learn to adapt
ourselves to that and like reasonable
people only you know think that that
things are trying to injure us when they
really are when they have the will when
they have the intention when they have
the capacity to do so and if we follow
that out we will certainly be much less
angry than we often are in our lives